The A-Z of isms... geocentrism.
Until the 16th Century,
geocentrism was a prevailing theory
of what the universe looked like.
Geocentrism is the belief
that the Earth,
our home planet,
is at the centre of the universe.
Everything else revolves around us.
This seemed obvious
to ancient astronomers,
after all they observed the sun and
the moon, the planets and the stars,
to move across the sky
as we go forward through time,
just like we do today.
So this must mean that the Earth
is in the centre of it all, right?
Wrong!
The earliest geocentric models
of ancient Greek
philosophers/scientists/general
all-rounders
such as Plato and Aristotle
in the 4th Century BC
placed a stationary
Earth at the centre
with the planets and the stars moving
around us on circles or spheres.
The thing is,
the simple geocentric model
couldn’t quite explain all that
we see when we watch the skies.
For a start,
the planets change brightness,
which shouldn’t happen
if they're always
the same distance from the Earth.
Second, the paths of Mars
and Jupiter through the sky
sometimes appear
to go backwards for a time,
which shouldn’t happen
if they're travelling round
in these neat little circles.
Despite this,
the theory had such a hold
and astronomers were so
convinced by it
that they spent hundreds of years
making all sorts of modifications
to try and make
the general theory fit.
And as needlessly complicated as it
now seems to modern astronomers,
this version of the universe proposed
by Ptolemy in the 2nd Century,
was almost universally accepted
for hundreds of years.
But not everyone was happy.
As far back as the 3rd Century BC,
Aristarchus of Samos
had suggested that the Sun
was in the centre of the universe.
And in the years that followed
Ptolemy's work
both European and Islamic scientists
started to question aspects
of his geocentric model.
Finally in the 16th Century,
Polish astronomer Copernicus
published his model of the universe,
which also put the Sun, not the
Earth, at the centre of it all.
This is known as heliocentrism,
and for the first time,
mainstream science took note.
Today we know that even heliocentrism
doesn’t tell the full story.
While the Sun may be at the centre
of our solar system,
it is just one
of over a hundred billion stars
in our Milky Way galaxy,
which is itself one of over
a hundred billion galaxies
in the observable universe.
Not only do we have to contend
with being just one of probably
countless planets out there,
modern cosmology tells us
that the Earth and our solar system
doesn't even occupy
a special place in the universe.
And in fact, it turns out that there
is no centre to this universe at all.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!